ti sei svegliato male pensi che la vita
faccia schifo sei cremoso e ringrazia il
cielo che ti sei svegliato guarda che
faccia avresti da morto non hai un soldo
bucato e per andare in vacanza 6 cremoso
puoi sempre mentire come fanno tutti
quanti senza un briciolo è pazzesco
la notte non riesce a prendere sonno no
non ci riesco stay cremoso d'armi di
giorno pessime notizie abbiamo appena
redatto il bilancio siamo sotto di 10
euro
go go
hai ragione
sono pensieroso anche io
lo stop ti sei scordato che oggi è il
compleanno di bob è che devi portare la
torta dei cremoso a questo ci pensiamo
noi ciao ragazzi bentornati a una
puntata di cucina buttata per questo
grande finale di stagione philadelphia
deciso di abbracciare questo format dopo
che sono anni che noi abbracciamo lei ed
è per questo che oggi faremo una cheese
cake semplice ma soprattutto super di
impatto infatti la forma che
utilizzeremo è pazzesca di per fare la
base avremo bisogno di 500 grammi di
biscotti 250 g di burro per fare la
crema invece avremo bisogno di 500
grammi di finale
200 g di zucchero a velo 500 grammi di
panna liquida 10 grammi di gelatina
scopa per il topping alla frutta invece
ha più bisogno di 500 grammi di frutta
tra cui fragole lamponi mirtilli bester
le albicocche e infine 100 g di zucchero
semolato
per prima cosa dobbiamo fare spaccare i
biscotti in maniera molto grossolana
a questo punto per vedete non sacchetto
da frigo bar a freezer 53 biscotti no
sto provando a rifare i con secondo la
cia è appreso un biscottino e nico
ragazzi quali ma cosa succede una
scienza da personale della sera parte di
germania una volta maciullato tutto
quanto andiamo a passare velocemente il
burro i micro onde cremoso il mondo deve
stare più remoto
troppo astio anche detto guarda il miur
ci prendiamo il burro a questo punto
pensiamo dentro ma che non diamo tutto
quanto la smettiamo giardini inglesi
puoi mangiare gli ingredienti
[Musica]
e questo è pazzo ragazze pensiero in
venuta un'idea pazzesca anche il terry
cole non viene come ospite di cucina
buttata è cucina poi assaggia il suo
piatto e poi passaggi subito dopo di lei
per questa estate ne parla non a caso
600.000 light lo fai mai a parte che non
ci arriverà mai a nicosia richiamo certo
mila lek tu lo sappia marginale ma io lo
faccio per ora che la prossima ve la
faccio io mamma mi regala parte della
città è una teca se mi fanno impazzire
più corso della tua faccia più che
carino stai facendo la lettiera adesso
iniziate ad appiattire tutto quanto
finché non vi ritroverete più o meno una
superficie i fan come si dice tutto
veramente male omogenea in una cosa del
genere non la possa tollerare veramente
sembra che tu non abbia fatto altro
nella vita perché siamo quasi
scrivendo even questa qui a questo punto
la buttiamo in frigo e cela
dimentichiamo dentro passiamo alla crema
prendere il 10 grammi di gelatina
mettere dell'acqua fredda e aspettare
appunto che sia mo li prendiamo un
pochino di panna e la mettiamo da parte
a questo punto versiamo 500 g di
philadelphia all'interno di una ciotola
zucchero rigorosamente avvero lolium un
pochino alla volta e ogni tanto assaggio
pure posso dire che sono molto contento
chi la pratica
sì e ne sono orgoglioso io tutto quello
che è che inciso lo adoro io lo uso come
base anche per la rebel band paolo
balbetta temi sapere quindi commenti se
volete vedere la mia red velvet 100.000
line per bergamo
accetto leader in ginocchio la spa
numero questo video ovunque
nel frattempo aggiungiamo alla fine ha
detto con lo zucchero a filo capanna
fredda e nel frattempo romanista
velocissimi prendiamo la panna e la
riscaldiamo e scalda tissima perdiamo a
questo punto la gelatina strizzata
perbene e uniamo la nel bicchiere
insieme colpa alla calda che è scomparsa
vanno alla mano fuori la tesi di un
disastro carne si prova dai quella era
la panna devi farmi mettere breath è
arrivato il momento di versare il nostro
composto all'interno della fornirà che è
quella un castello
questa è la parte più bella del figlio
la crema e in freezer e biscotto è in
frigo ci vediamo domattina come la
mattina i schei fa riposare bagnato
mattina e riccò è il giorno dopo quello
che ci tengo a dire ovviamente se
volevate l'intero nino tortiera con la
cerniera basta aspettare due ore
mettete il biscotto mettete la crema di
formaggio e poi il topping che vi faremo
vedere adesso siccome noi volevamo fare
i fichi ha dovuto aspettare di più per
riuscire a fare questo castello quando
le ciance partiamo subito con il topping
alla frutta ecco le nostre fragole
perfettamente pulite bene a tutte quante
infiliamo qua dentro
andiamo a crollare ma l'ho sentito
prendiamo questo qui versiamo meta a
questo punto aggiungiamo lo zucchero 100
g accendiamo il fuoco e lo facciamo
restringere la reazione di maillard
d'oca aspettare quella in cucina bisogna
avere pazienza su cui si stanno
apprendendo cara la pasta signori
guardate che cosa ho fatto che si è
scoraggiata un attimo e bollente vabbè
che il suo non la saggi mi vuoi far
fuori una marmellata ma passaggio
direttamente apple li metto dentro non
ha capito e soltanto che ancora di loro
fa rappresa non vi prego vi prego estate
ripetendo il tutto il video c'erano non
vedete l'ora di ti senti soddisfatto da
morire ammettiamo dentro il composto a
crudo e frattanto giriamo a genova da
amalgamare tutto quanto la fine avremo
questo poi mettiamo in frigo a
riscaldarsi a questo punto abbiamo il
biscotto e abbiamo preso un piatto
dobbiamo aprire la cerniera e sperare
che si stacchi e c'è una cena credete
che serio del momento intanto di
piazzare il nostro castello di cisterna
philadelphia bravo e poi un castello no
tu lo metti una formina del castello e
che ogni mamma mia vuole rompere tutto
si sentiva stufato sterminio 2006
e ora procediamo fra poco
ok è passato del tempo adesso il topping
è perfettamente fresco guardate la
bellezza di questo top ring inoltre è
anche arrivata la creatrice di questa
ricetta giulia non far finta di non
esserci
tu sei venuta qui per darmi delle dritte
su come decorarla si sa giulia stanno
bene va bene ci si mette un bel frutto
sembra ma base di sughero se ne fa le
cose troppo precisi secondo me amano
perché gusto pasticcera giusto io ho un
gusto del cafone del popolo dalla
bicocca dai giu ok latorre fara visto
che ho portato queste fondi di venture
delle lore piazzerei mai tac come gli
azionisti giulia il tesoro di ride è
venuta questa antenna uno stress
pazzesco
devo un po di movimento questa traversa
ho portato i pirati e ho portato gli
unicorni che secondo me con la frutta il
cartello così faceva più carino ma la
mia vera anima e pirata quindi decidete
voi cosa volete mette e ho tirato un
traffico di armi chissenefrega dubbi che
cominciamo a intravedere un senso delle
decorazioni
sì lo so ci sto pensando a tutto quanto
no giuliani notte è bella e bellissimo
ragazzi
[Musica]
allora l'aspetto è pazzesco racca è una
di quelle cose che se la tiri fuori
persone non ci crederanno mai che le
fatto a te ma anche io ci credo ancora
che non parta io che un bell'esemplare
di cheesecake secondo me terreti tosa io
credo a dieci ragazzi si presenta
benissimo aspetta prova a levare
l'unicorno voto do 9 e mezzo ma perché
io 10 deluderò mai un soldato che per
una tartara cielo serale come è uno e
mezzo in realtà mi accodo subito con
guglielmo voto 9 un bell 8 e mezzo non
glielo leva nessuno sa dove si sente un
sacco di topping di fragola neonato
sempre più in frutti di bosco
interessante io ho sentito anche molto
il filadelfia piacevole in realtà si
sente tutto è buonissimo un odore 8 da
1918 ci fa tutto anche si capisce che
non vedono di assaggiarla non vedo l'ora
di assaggiare le ha prese chiamata e ora
biscotto un po durello le assenze che è
un erezione
mamma mia e la spada nella roccia
la torta del secolo eccezionale berlina
i sapori 10 un pazzesco
io le do 9 e mezzo il mezzo che manca è
solo perché non sono proprio diciamo la
più grande fan dei dolci chiudono
l'amante di torte dolci e cose varie
una cosa squisita questa ombra donazioni
giulia 99 mezzo fa cup risposto che per
me la cheesecake non è ancora il candide
bussasse alla porta va fatta ma la
figlia del pirata eccezionale vi prego
fate a casa però giuliano e poi con
questo unicorno e operatori per i giorni
se ne frega
tutto nella bocca per questo piatto ma
non so quanto può costare la torta
intera più e fare un business per tutta
la torta rimanere umile 50 euro 50 però
è a posto con tutta l'esperienza del
fossato che sia perché scena o chi le fa
una torta così cioè pagherei con la
frazione di guglielmo 50 euro tutti una
singola fetta io la metterei a 7 euro 8
era una fetta 10 12 e li spenderei per
una meta ben così grande anch'io di 12
euro
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video ringrazio ancora più
energia perché è stato un modo
meraviglioso per chiudere in bellezza
questo hanno passato insieme con cucina
buttata vi ricordo ancora che avremo
degli episodi per tutto agosto che
saranno la nostra summer edition come
sempre l'invito a iscrivervi a questo
canale ad attivare le notifiche avete
subito un l'ipad enrico a non dobbiamo
arrivare al 100 e unire miracle worker e
vi prego i supplico non so come dirlo e
se non siete iscritti a questo canale
mettete prima un like per enrico poi se
volete iscrivetevi noi ci farà solamente
piacere avervi a bordo vi chiedo inoltre
dal momento che i social sono un posto
del quale ci si lamenta tanto ma si
condividono poche volte nelle cose
positive di farci sapere qua sotto quali
sono delle situazioni nelle quali siete
stati cremosi ispirate c con delle
notizie belle delle cose carine che
possano permettere a chiunque scrolli e
leghe commenti di farci una risata o di
sorridere per voi e di allietarci la
giornata al prossimo video chat che ci
vogliamo in vacanza
sono anzi lascia tutti i maledetti 1
tempo direttiva la rete ha premuto e
cremosa problema si arrivò che si stanno
mangiando la torta dei cremoso di chi
usa un cavolo